so und jetzt mal eher eine bedrückende
Nachricht neueste Berechnung sagen bis
2035 gehen uns weitere 7 Millionen
Arbeitskräfte verloren weil sie in Rente
gehen ja sie ahnen über wen wir reden
die gottverdammten Babyboomer hallo
ja wir werden einfach immer älter und
keiner kann uns aufhalten ab 2025
beginnt die Boomer Verrentung und dann
wird es eng in der Rentenkasse was tun
vor allem die Arbeitgeber kommen da
eigentlich immer mit derselben Idee
gefälligst bis 70 malochen also wenn
sich schätzen wie viele Leute würden
sagen ja arbeiten bis 70 bin ich voll
dabei
bei uns hier würde ich mal sagen
mir hat sehr gut gefallen wie er das im
Kopf nachrechnet
Null ja ja so lange arbeiten für
bestimmte Berufe wie zum Beispiel
Dachdecker völlig und denkbar weiß man
aber klar aus Arbeitgebersicht sieht der
perfekte Rentner natürlich so aus mit 70
hat er den letzten Arbeitstag kriegt
eine goldene Uhr schöne sich einen
Kaffee ein und kneift den Pötter zu
Feierabend ja das ist Patriotismus
für Deutschland gilt eine akute
Reisewarnung früher haben sechs
Arbeitnehmer einen Rentner finanziert
heute sind es 1,8 pro gerund ja 2050
werden es sogar nur noch 1,3 sein für
Berufseinsteiger von heute ist unser
deutsches Rentensystem also jetzt nicht
komplett für die Schüssel aber
sie müssen möglicherweise deutlich
länger und mehr einzahlen um am Ende
weniger rauszukriegen als wir
überhaupt nicht lustig ich werde sehr
wahrscheinlich dass viele in ihrer
Generation die jetzt heute Mitte 20 sind
erst mit 70 oder vielleicht 75 damit 80
in Rente gehen
ganz ehrlich wenn ich 20 wäre ich würde
mich als Aktivist jeden Tag an
irgendeinen Rentner dran kleben ja ja
statt Flughäfen zu belästigen und dann
boomt auch noch die Rente mit 63 gerade
wie Hulle allein im letzten Jahr sind
269.000 deutsche damit abschlagsfrei in
Rente gegangen ja das waren
26,3% aller neu Rentner
aber was machen wir jetzt was kann man
tun laut einer aktuellen Umfrage wollen
nur 10,7 Prozent der Menschen bis 67
oder länger arbeiten wir könnten
Arbeitsplätze attraktiver machen und es
bräuchte bessere Kinderbetreuung damit
mehr Frauen Vollzeit arbeiten
qualifizierte Zuwanderung oder
wir machen das Rentnerleben so
unattraktiv dass alle freiwillig länger
arbeiten Vorschlag Menschen über 60
dürfen nicht mehr an Kreuzfahrten
teilnehmen keine Wohnmobile mehr kaufen
und noch wichtiger keine E-Bikes
stattdessen fahren Sie nur noch alte
Hollandräder mit ausgeleierter
Gangschaltung ohne Helm ganz wichtig für
die Rentenkasse
ältere Frauen dürfen keine bunten
Leggings mehr tragen und sich
ausdrücklich nicht die Haare Aubergine
färben sie tragen nur noch böse
Funktionsjacken und bilden mit ihrem
Mann ein unisex Rentner Ehepaar wo die
Mann der Frau ist und umgekehrt ja die
müssen weniger Spaß haben in der Rente
so wird ein orthopädischer Schuh draus
ja
und leider gehört soweit sind unter
denen die bei uns länger arbeiten viele
die gar keine andere Wahl haben ja ist
eine Tatsache die meisten Niedriglöhner
haben in unserem System 0 Chance der
Altersarmut zu entgehen trotz
lebenslanger Arbeit ab weil sie einfach
nicht genug einzahlen konnten das ist
eine Riesensauerei und den hilft
übrigens auch nicht die tolle neue
aktienrente die im Januar startet dafür
leiht sich der Staat wir haben ja noch
nicht genug Schulden erstmal 10
Milliarden und das viele Geld dass man
damit an der Börse hoffentlich macht
landet dann irgendwann in der
Rentenkasse läuft ja gerade supi an der
Börse warum nicht Vorbild ist unter
anderem der schwedische staatsfon
Begriff oder und wenn man sich anguckt
was die da so ziemlich unbürokratisch
hinkriegen die alten Schweden zieht ein
das als Deutscher irgendwie runter die
staatliche Behörde AP7 hier liegt das
Geld von Jan Böckmann und Millionen
anderer Schweden 58 Milliarden Euro
verwaltet von 36 Menschen ja bei uns
werden es wahrscheinlich 58 Milliarden
Beamte für 36 Euro
tatsächlich stecken die Schweden aber
auch die Norweger viel mehr Geld in ihre
Aktien Rentenkasse 10 Milliarden im Jahr
wie die Ampel das ab Januar versucht
reicht nicht ansatzweise um die Boomer
Mehrkosten zu decken heißt wir brauchen
eine echte Reform Beispiel Beamte und
Selbstständige müssen endlich auch
einzahlen die deutsche Rente reden wir
darüber mit einem Mann der in seinem
überalterten Heimatland Sachsen quasi
als Teenager gilt mit Olaf Schubert oder
schön dass du da bist Rente mit 70 was
hältst Du davon wer das für dich eine
Option
ja also mit 70 aufhören zu arbeiten wäre
für mich zu früh
weil ich muss ja erstmal anfangen also
ja ich wollte immer arbeiten aber hat
sich nie ergeben
ich meine das hier ist ja ehrenamtlich
ich sage ganz klar aber ich kann mir
vorstellen länger arbeiten ist für viele
ein Thema der Deutsche ist ja richtig
die sind ja alle Mops Fidel ja null Bock
auf Friedhof der Deutsche ist ja so
drauf der macht einfach weiter ja das
siebte Frühling mit den sechsten Zähnen
und da werden sich viele sagen klar hier
noch so paar Gleise verlegen warum nicht
ähm mit 70 Arbeiten denke ich wird
funktionieren allerdings werden dann
guckt man drei Minuten werden das
und denkt ja betreutes moderieren ist es
vielleicht auch nicht also ich bin aber
prinzipiell positiv eingestellt ja eine
Lösung ich habe schon angesprochen wäre
ja die Beteiligung die stärkere
Beteiligung von Frauen am Arbeitsmarkt
dann bräuchten wir aber auch eine
bessere Kinderbetreuung wäre das so die
lösen ja ich denke da wurde ja auch
schon viel unternommen und wir wissen ja
alle ja Frauen können arbeiten
na ja scheinbar wollen sie nicht ja also
das ist ja
ich meine Kinderbetreuung was da eben
hauptsächlich immer
ich finde das mehr eine Beschäftigung ja
also ja jetzt irgendwie so eine Kiste
Lego ins Zimmer kippen und und bloß weil
es dort wo ich gerade bin weil es dort
laut ist und schlechte Luft deshalb ist
das was ich mache nicht automatisch
Arbeit
ja da könnte ich mich ja auch mit dem
Kasten Bier und die Autobahn setzen so
ja aber natürlich ist das ja auch
Potenzial ja Erzieherin eigentlich geht
es darum dass man die irgendwie umrüstet
für die Produktion und ich meine
Kinderbetreuung überwinden ja also meine
warum sollen die Frauen die Kinder nicht
mitnehmen auf Arbeit und wenn es einmal
da sind dann können Sie gleich mit
Anfassen ja was weiß ich nicht die Mutti
ist Chirurgin die schneidet den Bauch
auf der kann das Kind schon mal ein
Bypass legen irgendwie ne die mit den
kleinen Händen die kommt auch viel
besser zwischen die Organe ja und was
soll passieren wenn man das Kind mit
einlädt irgendwie das wird sich schon
melden ja in der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland leben aktuell so wenig junge
Menschen wie noch nie zuvor eine Zahl
hat mich wirklich umgehauen der Anteil
der 15 bis 24 Jährigen liegt bei nur
noch
10%. was machen wir damit die
Geburtenrate wieder besser wird
ja man müsste versuchen das zu
kompensieren indem man eben versucht
jetzt vermehrt 15-jährige zu zeugen
ist schwierig natürlich der
demokratische Wandel ist ja da ja in der
Schule habe ich ja noch gelernt es gibt
die
Bevölkerungspyramide ja also unten viele
junge Menschen oben weniger alte aber in
den letzten Jahrzehnten kamen sie dann
zu
Spliss in der Hypotenuse
und jetzt haben wir einen
bevölkerungseimer also
und und die Prognose ist wirklich düster
es gibt ja diese Studie bei
westeuropäischen Männern hat sich ja in
den letzten 50 Jahren die Anzahl der
Spermien im Ejakulat
halbiert bei den westeuropäischen
Männern also ich bin da raus
ja also wir heizen quasi noch mit
Restbeständen von
volkseigenen samenkombinat
aber die Frage ist ja wohin geht die
Reise und ich glaube viele Menschen
wollen sich vor Pflanzen aber die lassen
sich eben auch zu leicht ablenken ja die
liegen schon nackt im Bett und dann auch
guck mal Bares
und hier muss natürlich eigentlich der
Staat eingreifen ja irgendwie da muss
man es auch Rabatt machen also es gibt
ja für alles so ein Amt oder so ein
Ministerium irgendwie Bundesministerium
für Männer und Sex ne kurz
und dann eben der Pandemie da müssen die
Leute in die Wohnung ja da gibt es so
ich sag mal fuckdown und ja man darf
eben nur raus wirklich dann mit
positiven Schwangerschaftstest und ich
könnte mir vorstellen dass greift er
während die Leute sagen kommen
Geschlechtsverkehr machen wir gleich
rüber weg
Olaf Schubert vielen Dank
[Applaus]
ja
Tatsache ist
keine Partei hat im Moment Bock auf das
Rentenproblem denn du machst dich als
Politiker bei mindestens einer Gruppe
mega unbeliebt und die Menschen in
Deutschland wollen aktuell nur noch gute
Nachrichten ein Mann hat das
offensichtlich verstanden Friedrich Merz
ja
CDU-Vorsitzender und führender
hobby-virologe anders kann ich mir das
folgende jedenfalls nicht erklären die
Zeit der hohen Infektionsgefahr mit
schweren Krankheitsverlauf ist vorbei
wir sollten zur Normalität zurückkehren
und spätestens im Frühjahr nächsten
Jahres Corona offiziell als beendet
erklären hurra ist das nicht toll und
wenn man dabei sind können wir bitte
auch gleich den Klimawandel und die
Fußball-WM für beendet erklären da würde
ich mich sehr freuen in vier
Bundesländern dürfen Corona positive
Menschen wieder zur Arbeit gehen trotz
Infektionen und dort ansteckende
Lebensfreude verbreiten ja gut alles auf
eine Art konsequent denn sie wissen die
Gesundheitsämter können die Isolation
bei uns eh nicht mehr kontrollieren
warum also nicht auf Eigenverantwortung
setzen worüber man vielleicht streiten
kann ist das Timing jetzt kommt das
kalte Wetter und die Grippewelle rollt
auch das könnte wenn es blöd läuft
heftig werden fürs Gesundheitssystem
Idee die Firmen sollten dann aber
wenigstens für jede Krankheit eine
eigene Büroetage freihalten
gute Besserung ja ich meine natürlich
rückblickend gab es in den corona-jahren
überzogene grundrechtseinschränkung ja
deshalb ist es auch völlig okay wenn
jetzt über die Verhältnismäßigkeit der
maskenpflicht in der Bahn diskutiert
wird als Beispiel lernen mit dem Virus
zu leben ist mit genug geimpften allemal
besser als die idiotische Null kovic
Strategie die gerade den Chinesen um die
Ohren fliegt unsere Politiker das dürfen
wir nie vergessen mussten brutale
Abwägung treffen und erzeugt es doch von
Größe im Nachhinein auch mal Fehler
zuzugeben nach dem Wissen von heute
kommt man klar zu der Kenntnis dass die
Kita Schließungen zu Beginn der Pandemie
nicht nötig gewesen wären
die kita-schließung waren also gar nicht
nötig wie kommt das so an bei den Eltern
die ihre Kinder damals wochenlang selber
betreuen mussten gibt es da schon
Reaktionen
[Applaus]
die aggressiv okay wir halten mal fest
Friedrich Merz beendet Corona offiziell
und unser ZDF hat direkt reagiert morgen
Abend läuft hier nach dem Erfolg von
Wetten dass direkt die nächste große
nostalgieshow gut bei Corona moderiert
von Tina hausten und Holger Stockhorst
wir schalten mal live zu den Proben in
die Nico Schlotterbeck Arena in
Wilhelmshaven Kinder auf was dürfen wir
uns da freuen ach Oliver wir blicken
zurück auf eine verrückte Zeit die
corona-jahre wie wir ausgesehen haben
mit diesem komischen Masken weißt du
noch Holger die Masken hatten alle
ja ich auch ja damit haben wir in der
Bahn gesessen wie die Vollidioten anyway
jetzt mit Abstand kann man immer so
vieles Lachen also wenn man nicht gerade
mit covid im Krankenhaus liegt ja allein
die ganzen Wortschöpfungen was zum
Henker war ein brückenlock da hauen
keine Sau mehr genau wie die erweiterte
osterruhe oder hier wie hieß der nochmal
dieses bekloppte Verbot
beherbergungsverbote beherbergungs ob
beherbergungsboot und beherberge
buchungsverbote der Herr Werbung
beherbergungsverbot bewerbungsverbot
beherbergungsverbot bzw beherberge
Beherbergung
ja genau das
ja ansonsten Oliver gehen wieder Frage
auf den Grund was hat Deutschland
gelernt aus dieser Pandemie so viel ja
zum Beispiel dass unsere Schulen gar
nicht richtig digitalisiert sind
wusstest du das Tina also ich wusste das
nicht ja und jetzt haben wir wegen
Corona massenweise iPads an die Schüler
verteilt um festzustellen viele Schulen
haben gar kein WLAN
macht aber nichts die benutzen die iPads
jetzt damit die Tische nicht so wackeln
ja und im nächsten Pandemie Winter
wissen die Schüler eh was zu tun ist
Liften und man muss sich vielleicht
wirklich ein bisschen was wärmeres noch
zum
Anziehen mitbringen vielleicht macht man
auch mal eine kleine Kniebeuge oder so
oder
klatscht in die Hände damit man ein
bisschen warm wird
[Applaus]
wunderbar Oliver das tut auch gerade den
dicken Kindern mal ganz gut ja
Oliver hier sind so crazy Sachen
abgegangen damals in den corona-jahren
da hätten wir den Bundestag eigentlich
abschaffen können denn alle wichtigen
Entscheidungen wurden abends einfach von
Karl Lauterbach und Markus Lanz
verkündet stimmt ja und der Hammer ist
Lauterbach war damals total beliebt
wirklich die Leute mochten denen ja man
muss dabei gewesen sein also der war ein
internationaler Mega-Star irgendwo kann
Lauterbach Lauterbach
Karl Lauterbach ist der du die Pandemie
ist dran lauterbach
also ich habe dazu also die wirklich
also bisschen Studien also gelesen
wirklich wahr gelesen nein dabei musste
man ja gar nichts lesen ja also man
musste auch kein Virologe sein jeder war
Experte so eine ganz normale
infektionskurbel beschäftigen sich damit
mal ich bin Mediziner beschäftigen sich
mit mit ich bin seit Jahrzehnten im
Massagebereich tätig
Thaimassage Salons waren endlich auf
Augenhöhe mit Professor Drosten aber du
Holger um mal ganz kurz ernst zu werden
was denkst du wie könnte man denn die
nächste Pandemie vermeiden gute Frage
Tina wir könnten Stichwort zuonose zum
Beispiel aufhören die Lebensräume von
Tieren zu zerstören oder die
Massentierhaltung beenden
[Gelächter]
das ist verrückter Hund
nichts davon werden wir machen nichts
ich wäre ja schon froh wenn sich der
Staat beim nächsten Mal nicht mehr so
abzocken lässt ja
ich sag nur Masken Deals oder was
kriminelle allein mit Testzentren
erbeutet haben man schätzt bis zu 1,2
Milliarden Euro was ist das war so
jeder konnte mit drei Klicks im Internet
ein Testzentrum eröffnen auch
berufskriminelle mit dutzenden ja es
wurden zu viele Tests abgerechnet und
ganze Testzentren gab es überhaupt nicht
ach ja all das werden wir morgen noch
mal nostalgisch abfeiern mit dem Corona
Sommer hält
ich habe einen Kopf doch mein
Testzentrum ist geiler bringt mehr Geld
als meine leider wofür brauche ich denn
die alle bei den Tests gibt's
nullkontrolle man was sich hierfür
[Musik]
hat mich gesehen
[Applaus]
nein ich mache hier gar nichts mehr
bevor ihr nicht den Kanal abonniert und
ein Like da lasst
ich habe die Schnauze voll
ja los lass ein Abo da